enjoy the last season lies lies
lots of love everyone Jane the Virgin is
in for some big surprises I've seen Go
Go the Jane the Virgin cast has become
one big family as the series comes to an
end that's really over and I don't want
it to be getting to explore new sides of
her after four and a half years five
years that's unbelievable fans we know
we're gonna get a spinoff but things
just won't ever be the same what are you
gonna miss oh man I love these people
we've had five years together and we've
grown together and we've become adults
together in a lot of ways and I'm just
gonna miss seeing gonna miss seeing them
every day I'm very I'm very harsh I
brushed we're sad to see the CW show end
after five seasons but here's what we
know about the new spin-off Jane the
novella I'm not involved in the first
season of the spin-off but you know you
never know where it goes in the future I
mean I know Jenny had an idea that she
wanted to have a series that utilize a
pool of actors like a poor actress
almost like American Horror Story where
they utilize a lot of the same actors
and different characters so you never
know there's always the possibility that
I will come back as somebody else so we
need to peel your mask back sin rostro
stone I want to be evil this time
meet the new Jane Jacquelyn grace Lopez
the former East Los High actress is the
show's leading lady
ETS learn Lopez will play Estella a
rising curator living a double life oh
well I'm so far one original cast member
has signed on to the project hey Olga
castaño
Yvonne Cole who plays Jane's beloved
abuela will return she will play a
Stella's adoptive mother in the series
it's no secret Gina Rodriguez is
involved she confirmed CW picked up the
show with this pic caption Jane will be
birthing a spinoff what
that's better than before but it's
unlikely Gina will appear on screen
instead she acts as an executive
producer and will be narrator of the
telenovela Gina will he be in the
spin-off what can you share on he's he's
the only character of the Smitha
monologue no we can't afford him yeah
nine hundred grand an episode like Big
Bang I want to also write the whole show
myself are you gonna work the spin-off
will mirror the setup of the original
series but feature a host of new faces
deadline reports Estella will have a
love triangle between her boyfriend
Louie and Felix a charming wealthy guy
Luanne is head of security while Felix
co owns a winery which is giving us
major Michael and Raphael vibes oh my
god
[Music]